this is a production of Cornell
University
great thanks for that introduction Jacob
I didn't realize today was cassava
themed but at least I'll be talking
about a rabbi list which was a daikon so
there we go so for today I just want to
generally introduce the concepts behind
one of my PhD projects to use deep
learning models to model transcriptional
processes across rabid OPS's and maize
and also show a little bit of the
preliminary data that I've done from
this work so just to start off we're all
very aware of the different
methodologies used to locate causal si
over the past decades of breeding and
we're familiar with key TL mapping and
also G wasps that we've recently
switched to because of its higher
resolution but we're still limited in
our resolution because of linkage and
it's still very difficult to separate
correlated variance with the actual
causal variance and so the question
always remains how can we increase the
resolution to target those actual causal
barriers
another thing we need to consider is
that at least with QTL and gos you are
directly relating the phenotype with the
genotype data through a linear model and
you're generally ignoring the complex
nonlinear biological processes that
underline these and at least recent
studies have have begun to associates or
the quantitative difference in genotype
with quantitative differences at the RNA
level the protein level and also
metabolite level and today I'll be
focusing on how I'm looking at the
transcriptional level between DNA and
RNA so the flavor of deep learning model
that I'm using is called a convolutional
neural network and you might be familiar
with the term from the context of image
recognition or image classification
where it's the current state of the art
and since convolution is a matrix
operation the first thing we're going to
do so our DNA is converted into a matrix
and so the way we do that is we're
simply going to have a matrix the length
of our sequence and for columns for our
ACTG and we're just going to put ones in
each column corresponding to the bases
so we're going to end up with a sparse
matrix of zeros and ones then
we're gonna do is we're going to take
our orange box here which is basically
our sliding window we also have
corresponding matrices known as filters
which I like to think of as sort of like
position weight matrices for those
familiar with that basically it's a
matrix that weights base occurrence in
certain positions of the window over
others what you're going to do is you're
going to multiply those two matrices
well do a convolution on two of those
matrices and the result you expect to be
higher in the right column which would
be a very dark red color if the two
matrices are more similar so if your
motif is in the window and so the way we
can sort of visualize that is if we
slide along the sequence and now we've
hit a match and we get a high output
value in the right-hand column so the
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to apply what's known as an
activation function and in this case
it's what's known as a real OOP
all the real ooh does is turn all the
negative values to zero and keeps all
your positive values the same way and
this is this is one of the examples of
nonlinear functions that we can use in
in neural networks so one diagram you
may be familiar with if you've seen a
couple of deep learning slides before is
this architecture diagram of the fully
connected layer these are typically done
after your convolutional layers and they
basically consists of a bunch of neurons
that are connected to each these are the
white dots to each of the output labels
from the previous layer with a series of
edges that each have their associated
weights and so all you're going to do
for each of those neurons is take each
of your output data multiply it by the
respective weight sum that result and
tie another activation function that's
your result and you're going to do this
for each layer of your model and then
your final layers your output layer and
that's just going to have what value you
want which in this in my case would be
mRNA expression levels so all of that is
assuming you have all the parameters
that you want you have your filter
matrices estimated you have those
weights s and but what if you're
starting from scratch with a data set
say RNA seek and you want to estimate
those parameters how do you do that
and so we just call it training neural
networks or training models which is
essentially
getting a model to the data and the way
we do that is we divide our input data
up into batches for each those batches
well first we're gonna initialize all
the parameters to small random values
and then we're going to take our first
batch we're gonna make a prediction
which should be pretty bad because it's
just a random model at this point then
we're gonna take the air from that
prediction and the model architecture
and feed that into a training algorithm
and that training algorithm is going to
tell us the direction to update those
parameters to minimize our air we're
going to repeat those steps until we're
out of data that's one epoch and then
normally you would run a couple of
epochs to converge on an accurate model
I do want to emphasize that these
filters I showed earlier they start out
random because you initialize them
randomly and as a consequence of the
training process they gradually become
more defined as motifs if you think of
them as pwms this way matrices and that
is one way that these CN NS can extract
features from your data because you
don't give it these filters in advance
it learns how to accurately predict
expression by learning these motifs so
one of the common criticisms of deep
learning models is that they're even
though they're highly predictive and
they get strong accuracies how do we
interpret what they're actually learning
and they're generally considered to have
low interpret ability but in recent
years there's been a number of
techniques to sort of open up that black
box and interpret what the model is
actually learning one of the example of
this is deep lift and the way deep lift
works simply is by taking a random
background sequence or a reference
sequence it could be some random DNA or
maybe tune to the background frequencies
of your specific organism and then you
take a true positive let's say a gene
that you expect to have high expression
you run those through the model and then
you can directly compare the
intermediate layers of the model and
determine basically what parts of the
input are most predictive of changes in
the output so some
results from or not recent but some
previous results from a postdoc in our
lab hi wang who gave the deep learning
seminar at the beginning of the semester
he took three ideas one was to use the
promoter sequence defined as 15 but
hundred base pairs around the
transcription start site the terminator
sequence is just 1500 based prisoner and
the transcription termination site and
also a combination of the two to predict
expression using a CNN and his results
are on the right and you can basically
see that the promoter and the Terminator
model did the best with our Squared's of
about 0.45 and I do want to emphasize
that though those R Squared's aren't
that high we don't expect to have an R
squared of 1 to predict expression from
sis regulatory sequence because that we
know that biologically that doesn't
explain all the variation there so these
are actually pretty good considering the
input data so another thing
talk about is how we can possibly extend
this mRNA model to generalize different
tissues so we know that the DNA is the
same in different tissues but things
like epigenetics can change but the
model isn't currently taking that into
account and so one way we can think of
is by adding extra columns to this
matrix that correspond to epigenetic
signals that would be present and differ
between tissues so that the model can
learn how to predict differences in
tissue expression and so one example to
be methylation open chromatin signals
histone modifications and also other
epigenetic marks and another concept
touch upon is transfer learning and the
way I like to explain it is teaching an
old dog new tricks you have a model that
you've already trained on one large data
set that achieves high accuracy and now
you want to apply that model in another
related data set that's probably smaller
so if you train a model from scratch you
would not get as high of an accuracy
probably but what you can do is freeze
some of the parameters in the first
model that's been trained on the related
data set and retrain only part of the
model in the smaller data set and you
would expect to achieve slightly higher
accuracy as the smaller data so how does
that apply in our case well if you take
a an organism like rabid offices which
generally has a more diverse and larger
collection of RNA seek data sets you
might say that we could train more
accurate models to predict a rabid
Office's expression and so because we
have a lot more data there but if we
want to transfer into a crop species
that probably doesn't have the diverse
array of data as a rabid abscess well
how could we do that well so if we go
back and think about the convolutional
neural network that I introduced earlier
this part of the network it's sort of
how you learn to it learns to identify
motifs at least of the convolution stage
and then the neural network stage is
really where it learns how these motifs
interact together to regulate and
modulate expression and so if we in this
example make the assumption that between
let's say a rabid office in maze these
motifs are conserved that drive
expression let's say their transcription
factor binding sites that don't change
but the way they relate to each other
and drive high or low expression differs
so what we can do is take an arab adaxes
train model erase let's say the last
layers weights and then retrain it on
May's data just those last parameters
and now we have a model that doesn't
have to relearn how to recognize motifs
but can just simply be tuned to the
species specific connections
and so this is some preliminary results
that I've done in a rabid Oxus using hi
small and so what you're looking at on
the left is a prediction of mean
expression across all tissues for all
genes and rabbit houses and what you can
sort of tell is that it's similar in
accuracy to highs model and if you
compare generally the distributions
across all tissues is the models what I
want to emphasize the models have
comparable results so they do also work
in a rabbit Alice's okay so the
questions that I want to answer with the
rest of this work is basically can these
multi tissue transcriptional models be
trained with epigenetic information is
this a good idea and will it generalize
across tissues another question I'd like
to add answer is can we train models on
one species for example a rabbit OPS's
and then use those as useful starting
models to retrain and retune in other
species to achieve similar accuracies
but with less available data all right
and with
just like to acknowledge the buckler lab
and specifically Heidi and Katherine and
Emery for their discussions on this
project as well as my funding sources
and I'd be happy to take any questions
[Applause]
great questions so the question was am i
training on only one or Abydos this
genotype or all that potentially
thousand and one so currently I'm only
training on Colombia zero the reference
genotype but the plan is to use all
thousand and one genotypes are there any
questions from zoom don't think so
okay well thank you very much Janice of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu